hi I'm Erik Bosse and now that Game of
Thrones season 7 is coming a ton of you
guys have been hitting me up asking
about this new theory of about who will
be revealed as the real hero of Westeros
when the series ends and yes I know I'm
wearing glasses I'm having issues of
contacts also want to look smarter for
this video anyway in this video I'm
going to get into some potential
spoilers for season seven of Game of
Thrones but really these are all just
theories and predictions based on stuff
that has already come up on the show and
in the book so far okay if you've been
following the show and eBooks closely
you're probably familiar with the
prophecy of azor Ahai also sometimes
referred to as the prince that was
promised now I'm going to go into the
back story on this prophecy but if you
feel like you already know it pretty
well I just want to get right to my
theory you can skip to this time so in
George RR Martin's universe the prince
that was promised was an ancient
prophecy leader who will deliver the
world from darkness according to legend
he will be born amidst smoke and salt
under a bleeding star and he will have a
song the Song of Ice and Fire
now obviously there's a lot of
metaphorical language here and a lot of
people over the years have interpreted
this differently naturally pretty much
everyone tries to exploit it for power
so one of the characters believed to be
the princess promise was Stannis
Baratheon in the eyes of lady Melisandre
he was actually considered the second
coming of azure a high nowas or a high
is an ancient legendary hero to the
followers of the Lord of Light for the
doora high wielded a fiery sword called
light bringer and people this religion
believed azor Ahai will be reborn as a
new person with his own fiery sword to
defeat the darkness brought on by the
others the White Walkers
so really Azure Ahai reborn and the
principles promise our kind of terms
that are just used interchangeably
nowadays people believe that they point
to the same prophetic figure now
Melisandre assumed that Stannis was as
or high reborn interpreting the red
comment that appeared in the sky in
season 2 to be the bleeding star but
considering the way things ended for
Stannis that's obviously not the case
now there was another character who
arrived so to speak under this bleeding
star around the same time Daenerys
Targaryen the miraculous birth of her
dragons at the end of season 1 was a key
symbolic Reber
for her character taking place amid
smoke and I guess salt maybe in that
salty desert sand or the tears she wept
for call Drogo again guys is all
metaphorical but the other popular
candidate for Azure Ahai reborn is Jon
Snow this guy freakin resurrected from
the dead with the help of Melisandre in
her prayers to the Lord of Light and
really more than anyone else in the show
Jon seems to be the most heroic leader
against the White Walkers but long
before these two people many believed
that the prince that was promised was
Rhaegar Targaryen including Rhaegar
himself he was known to be a singer and
an amazing swordsman and in book three
Daenerys learned that her late brother
found something in a scroll and decided
that he must become a warrior I'm
guessing it was this prophecy also in
the books and Daenerys is vision she
sees her brother holding the baby Aegon
Targaryen cryptically saying he is the
prince that was promised and his is a
Song of Ice and Fire
now of course that baby was horribly
murdered by mountain Gregor Clegane in
the sack of King's Landing so that
wasn't a case but we also know that
Rhaegar had another baby Jon Snow so
maybe this is more evidence that jon is
the prince that was promised anyway
there are also just a ton of alternate
theories that azor Ahai could be someone
else like brand Arya Tyrion Samwell
Tarly just kidding no one thinks of him
but the newest theory out there is that
Zora hi reborn is Jaime Lannister the
Kingslayer the villainous incestuous
twin brother turns more redemptive but
little kind of incestuous hero and
here's why this guy could end up saving
all of Westeros by the end of the series
so according to legend azor Ahai created
his flaming sword Lightbringer in a
three-step forging process and again all
these details are really meant to be
metaphor that we can interpret and apply
to other people who have similar
parallel journeys so first Ozora hai
forged for 30 days and 30 nights and
then he tempered the sword in water but
the sword broke so the second time he
spent 50 days and 50 nights and tempered
it by plunging it into the heart of a
lion lie on but again the steel
shattered and the third time he spent
100 days in 100
nice and he called in his wife Nissa
Nissa and drove the sword into her heart
and her soul merged with the steel to
create Lightbringer and if you think
about it these three crucial steps
correspond to Jaime's character arc
transitioning him from the detestable
Kingslayer to the more heroic Jaime
Lannister so one of the first big
character moments for Jaime both in the
books and in the show was right after he
lost his hand remember he took a bath
with Brienne and breaks down emotionally
as well as physically revealing his side
of the story that led to his famous
nickname of Kingslayer so just like when
adora high-tempered his first sword and
water it shattered when Jamie goes into
the water he breaks as well pay close
attention to how this confession scene
in so this is Jamie's rebirth breaking
out of this Kingslayer she'll to become
a more morally complex hero okay so
another key step for Jaime's growth as a
character was the breaking a part of the
Lannister family structure so throughout
season 4 Jaime rapidly loses his son
Joffrey followed by his father Tywin
which results in the exile of his
brother Tyrion in fact it was Jaime's
decision to defy his father in free
Tyrion that led to Tyrion killing Tywin
by firing an arrow directly into his
heart of course Tywin was the patriarch
of the Lannisters whose sigil is the
lion and as Cersei coldly told Jaime a
Tywin funeral it was Jaime's actions
that killed their daddy lion do you
maybe come follow me
you killed him by mistake stupidity so
by breaking away from this pride of
lions Jaime parallels the second step of
azure highs forging plunging the sword
into the heart of the lion and that
brings us to the final step as aura
highs sacrifice of its wife and
companion makes Anissa and here's where
things get interesting
so besides Ozora high and the prince
that was promised another key prophecy
in Game of Thrones was the one that
Cersei received as a young girl from the
wood witch who's Maggie the frog in the
books so even though this doesn't happen
in the show in the book Cersei is also
told that she will die by the hand of
her balloon car and that's the
Liron word for younger brother now
Cersei has always interpreted that
younger brother to be Tyrion which is
one of the reasons she's always been so
suspicious of them remember in season 2
tyrion threatens her with this line the
day would come when you think you're
safe and happy and your joy will turn to
ashes in your mouth and that thread has
always haunted her but now it appears at
that Valon car could be a different
younger brother her twin brother Jaime
Lannister who was born a few minutes
after her so remember Cersei just blew
up a huge piece of King's Landing using
the same jars of wildfire that the Mad
King stored beneath the city the same
war crime that Jaime slew that King to
prevent so now that Cersei has become a
bit of a mad queen it's possible that
Jaime might repeat history fulfilling
his destiny both as the bull and car and
Ozora high sacrificing his longtime
companions who create light bringer now
what would this fiery sword look like so
in my breakdown of the season 7 trailer
I talked about how Jaime's new sword
widow's wail was one of the twin
Valyrian steel swords that Tywin melted
down from the Starks sword I and yeah
maybe the moment that Jaime drives this
sword into Circe's heart it'll burst
into flames mania at the same time
Brienne sword Oathkeeper will also burst
into flames since they were forged from
the same steel ice a song of ice on fire
but I think that there's another equally
awesome way this could go also in that
season 7 breakdown I pointed out how in
that shot of the large floor map and the
red Keith Cersei is standing on the neck
of Westeros but what I didn't point out
is that Jaime is standing right beside
the east coast of Westeros and these
narrow peninsulas are called the fingers
so this shot could be foreshadowing
Jaime using his literal fingers to
strangle Cersei around her neck but then
again remember that threat from Tyrion
and you'll joy was turned to ashes in
your mouth so it could be that light
bringer doesn't refer to a literal sword
but Jamie's golden hand bursting into
flames as he choked Cersei causing
literal ashes to form in her mouth so
yeah is it pretty gruesome
but pretty epic and poetically justified
wafers cersei to die
considering the masses she burned at the
end of last season and yeah I know this
sounds crazy but when he looked back
this visual has been foreshadowed
throughout the series
so first in book 3 right after Jamie's
hand is cut off there's this passage his
hand burned and its fingers twisting in
the flames the fingers can no longer had
also in the show and that chemo and I
talked about when Jamie freed Tyrion
Jamie holds a fiery torch and it flashes
in front of the camera and so that one
could be stretching but there was also
this pivotal moment in the first episode
when brand caught Jaime and Cersei in
the act and Jaime's hand is around
Cersei throat so Jaime's iconic line of
Kings Methuselah could come full circle
later when he's now turned on Cersei and
speaking of bran in season four there's
an interesting scene where bran Meera
and Jojen Reed speculate on their
journey specifically how it would end
this is an end how well we know yet
so remember Jojen Reed would dream
visions of the future and maybe this is
jochen's way of saying that they'll know
it's the end when Ozora high returns to
vanquish the White Walkers with his
light bringer being a hand of fire also
here's a fun detail that could connect
Jamie to the Lord of Light prophecy the
Valyrian words for Lord and light is key
oh and oh noes are weirdly similar to a
ski on an own dose which translates to
gold hand though it could be that over
thousands of years this prophecy just
got lost in translation and the Lord of
lights champion was always destined to
be the man with the golden hand now just
to be clear I filled in Game of Thrones
seems way more focused on Jon and
Daenerys as the heroes of the story like
the two of them have both experienced
classic hero's journeys highborn
children and exile traveling to the far
corners of the world coming back from
death to become leaders of men but I
would argue that Jamie has experienced
the most personal growth remember we
hated this guy in that first episode but
then over time he completely transformed
into a hero that we kind of liked but
what are your thoughts does Jamie
Dinah's or Ahai reborn sound like a
satisfying conclusion for this whole
series or does that idea take away
significance from other characters like
guys that would mean the principal
promise can't be Sam I know hearts are
breaking but do you think that there's
any other unexpected character that you
predict will be revealed as or high
reborn or do you think the show can get
away with not even resolving this mister
at all appears to hear any theories that
you have let me know down in the
comments and again make sure to check
out my season 7 trailer breakdown for
more predictions and missable clues
about this new season and if you like
this video please hit like it subscribe
to new rockstars and if you really like
us you can contribute to us on patreon
thank you so much to all of our current
patrons especially Matthew Sava you can
hit me up on Twitter a TA box with any
thoughts do you have about Game of
Thrones season 7 or follow new rock
stars on Twitter at new rock stars for
updates on our videos ok thanks for
watching bye
you